Oh la bonne idée j'vais faire une vidéo sur Pokémon Go
Je vais être le premier ! Je suis le dernier en fait merde...
Quand ils ont annoncé Pokémon Go
Y'a un peu moins d'un an, j'étais comme un dingue avec la vidéo de promo là !
*Vidéo de promo de POKEMON GO avec une musique épique*
*Bruit de pet avec la musique un peu nulle du jeu*
Ouais, on peut dire qu'on s'est fait douiller dans l'histoire.
Vous avez vu les échanges de Pokémons, hein ?
Et ça ça n'existe pas dans le jeu...
Ils ont même régressé avec la mise à jour, on sait même plus la distance avec les Pokémons
On sait plus où ils sont !
*pffrt*
Mais j'me'n fous, j'ai des Pokémons
dans mon téléphone ! *Musique de la victoire*
Quand j'ai lancé le jeu, j'étais un petit peu étonné
parce que tout mes potes me disait :
Ouais, j'ai un Scarabrute, sur le chemin j'ai attrapé un Insécateur à côté d'un Tortank, si tu veux
Moi, j'dois pas avoir le même jeu
Moi j'ai RoucoolGO
Voila les pokémons qu'il y a autour de moi.
Qu'est ce qu'il y a.. je... je suis pas digne d'attraper autre chose ? C'est ça ?
Moi j'ai attrapper des centaines de Roucool,
ça fait un petit peu d'expérience ensuite je les supprime,
enfin non, je les transfère au professeur, c'est dit comme ça dans le jeu c'est moins violent.
Moi j'ai transferé des centaines de Roucool au professeur.
Qu'est ce qu'il en fait des Roucool ?
Chérie, j'ai fait à manger j'ai fait du Roucool, DE la volaille
Quoi, encore?
Oui encore, ça va être comme ça toute la semaine! OK?
Eh les mecs, vous êtes super chauds, j'avais à peine commencé le jeu, je m'approche d'une arène
Pour voir un petit peu les pokémon des autres,
Vous faites des pauses des fois ?
Regarde ce que je viens d'attraper
C'est mon plus fort Pokémon!!
Ouah c'est bien... Du coup, on vas faire un combat !
Non
Si, si !
Dracolosse, ultra-laser.
Bonne journée
D'ailleurs, y'a quelques jours, j'me promenais,
et là je vois pas loin une arène d'un niveau convenable, ce qui est assez rare pour le souligner
Du coup, je fais un détour et quand j'arrive, je vois le mec de l'arène qui attendait
Là j'ai totalement paniqué,
Parce que si je m'arrêtais et je me mettais à jouer, ça voulais dire que j'étais en train de le défoncer quoi.
Du coup, j'ai.... rien fait.
Eh mais il a pris mon arène !
*Bruits de Cyprien qui joue à Pokémon GO en prenant l'arène du mec assis sur le banc qui ressemble à Squeezie (le mec pas le banc)*
Alors le système d'arène, pour ceux qui vivent dans une grotte.
Les joueurs sont dans deux équipes : les rouges ou les bleus
et ils doivent mettre un pokémon dans... t'as oublié les jaunes
Ah, j'ai oublié les jaunes
Mais qui prend les jaunes ?
Bonjour, je m'appelle Julien Jaune, à l'école, tout le monde avait une calculatrice CASIO, moi j'avais une Texas Instruments.
J'adore aller sur Dailymotion, pour voir mes vidéastes préférés.
(Journaliste) Vous répondez quoi aux gens qui disent que vous êtes différent ?
(Julien) Je suis pas différent.
Je suis jaune.
(Cyprien) Alors, pour récupérer des pokéballs, des potions, tout ça, tu t'arrêtes à des Pokéstops, y en a tous les 2m à Paris.
Mon sac est tout le temps plein, je passe mon temps à jeter des pokéballs
(Mec) Tu jettes des poké... Je dois faire 15km pour trouver le premier pokéstop, c'est le seul de la région !
J'ai croisé un Carabaffe, j'avais plus de pokéball pour l'attraper ! (Pleurs) IL JETTES DES POKEBALLS!
ceci est un message de la campagne plus de pokéstop s'il vous plait ...
(Cyprien) C'est marrant, parce que Pokémon GO, ça a créer une nouvelle dynamique.
Avant, les parents disaient ça :
(Mère) Non mais Théo, t'es encore sur ton ordinateur enfermé toute la journée, sors un petit peu ! Il fait beau !
(Cyprien) Et maintenant...
(Mère) Théo, reviens !
Tu es où ?
(Cyprien) Du coup, les gamins, ils sont perdus.
(Mère) Sors un peu, Cyprien. Rentre à la maison ! Sors ! Rentre ! Sors ! Rentre ! Sors ! Ça s'en va et ça reviens !
(Cyprien) Tout le monde jouent à Pokémon GO. Dans les rues, dans les parcs, tu reconnais les joueurs parce qu'ils marchent comme ça.
Et si en plus, ils ont une batterie externe, lui, il faut pas le faire chier !
Il est là pour botter des culs dans les arènes, mettre son Pokémon niveau 2000, attraper des Mini-Draco, les faire évoluer en Dracolosse, faut pas le faire chier !
Et puis, il y a ceux qui ont honte, j'en ai déjà croisé, quand je passe à côté d'eux, paf, ils cachent un peu leur écran genre : "Non mais euh, je suis pas sur Pokémon GO..."
Sauf que dès qu'ils passent derrière moi, paf, je me retourne, tel un espion soviétique, et là, j'aime bien leur crier :
ALORS ? ÇA ATTRAPE DU POKÉMON ?
(Dresseur) Oui, je viens d'avoir un Ponyta.
(Cyprien) Oh moi, j'ai un œuf qui éclot !
(Squeezie dresseur) Ça doit être un truc super rare !
(Cyprien) Super rare, regarde ! (Dresseur Squeezie) C'est sûr !
(Dresseur Squeezie) Oh, je suis désolé, attends, moi aussi, j'ai un œuf qui éclot ! Oh, un Léviator ! Allez, bonne journée !
(Cyprien) Ben, nickel !
T'as un œuf, tu marches plusieurs kilomètres sur 150 Pokémons c'est un putain de Roucool qui en sort !
Bien le jeu ! (Applaudissements)
Bien ! Le jeu est un carton ! Donc, il a son lot de critiques, j'ai entendu pas mal :
Les gens sont dans les parcs, mais ils sont rivés sur leur téléphone, ils profitent pas trop, levez un petit peu les yeux !
Ahhhh... Levez les yeux... Ah oui, pour profiter... hm,hmm...
Ils disent pareil à ceux qui lisent un livre dans un parc ?
Lève les yeux, putain ! Profite un peu ! (Squeezie) Oui d'accord, je lève les yeux !
(Cyprien) Oui bien sûr, je dis pas, le phénomène, il est impressionnant, il y a 75 millions de téléchargements, des regroupements dans les parcs, on a vu ce qui se passe quand il y a un Pokémon rare qui apparaît :
(Cris de la foule)
Alors oui, quand je vois ça, euh, bien sûr, je veux dire, les mecs... (sifflement)
C'est quoi comme Pokémon exactement ? C'est un Dracolosse ? Un Léviator ? Il est où ?
Alors, j'ai l'impression qu'il y a des gens, qui veulent absolument prouver que le jeu est dangereux.
'Faut que ça soit dangereux, trouve un truc, il faut que ça soit dangereux, s'il te plait !
Je suis un média, il faut que je trouve un article, pour dire que Pokémon, ça tue des gens, stp !
Un automobiliste a créé un accident alors qu'il roulait pendant qu'il jouait à Pokémon GO.
Eh ben voilà, c'est dangereux, je l'avais dit que c'était dangereux, j'ai vu la photo sur Facebook avec le Pikachu sur le cou, ben oui, je l'ai vu, je l'ai même partagé !
Attends, si quelqu'un a un accident, c'est pas de la faute de Pokémon GO. C'est de la faute de sa connerie, de pas respecter le code de la route !
S'il vous plait, arrêtez de tout diaboliser, c'est juste un jeu, et moi, ça me rappelle de super bons souvenirs avec les musiques, les pokémons, ça me fait prendre l'air, je rencontre des gens, je collectionne les Roucools, et peut-être, qui sait :
♫ Un jour, je serai le meilleur dresseur ! Je me battrais sans répit ! Je ferai tout pour...
Ah oui, vous vous demandez peut-être quelle team je suis ?
Vous savez, au collège, j'avais une Texas Instruments....
[Sous titres par Ocylanos, SansTheSkeleton1, On parodie l'actualité !, UGO, Whipdred et Viveles Urbanways]